I turn to my left and I see a guy that
I'm thrilled to have right here on the
Rich Eisen Show set not only because he
is one of the best people and
high-quality quarterbacks in the
National Football League for the Houston
Texas but most importantly was my
fantasy football quarterback this year
this year he is the Shawn Watson good to
see you sir nice seeing you
that's also an applause line how's
everything in your life it's a great man
it's a blessing I was able to go to the
Pro Bowl which was awesome so that was a
good experience and it came came
straight here and good to be back home
it's actually right man and you uh you
have just electrified the league and
obviously your first playoff experience
in the NFL this year what was that like
it was different I can feel I can tell
that it was a whole different season a
new energy and new vibe and it was good
to be able to play it in and kind of
experience you know that I guess the
loss early DeSean it's happened to so
many people I mean of the 12
quarterbacks that made the playoffs this
year only mahomes joined Russell Wilson
and Tom Brady is the only quarterbacks
in the field who won their first playoff
for sure it happens to virtually
everybody so I'm wondering is it
different this is very different
especially going against the co so we
played three times that's right they
know everything we're doing we know
everything they're doing so it makes the
game a little harder but yeah it was a
different energy and different type of
game for sure so in terms of preparation
that's one thing but when you get out
there and you just felt it you just feel
the intensity was very different it's
not amazing because most of the people
on the Colts to it never played a riot
game before right is that just happens
she's just having some times so when
you're walking around a Super Bowl week
how often do you dream of playing and in
this game that's the biggest biggest
goal be his dream that uh you know
especially everyone in the Houston
organization have and it would have been
cool to be able to come home and play in
it but for sure you know especially
welcome around this week I want to be
playing in it
okay and being teammates with a fellow
Clemson Tiger in DeAndre Hopkins what
does that mean that you guys can
represent Clemson at the next level
together
it's awesome just to be able to have
that connection you know they have that
Clemson prior Tiger pride and in the
Houston so everywhere we go we always
see some orange in the stands you know
it's good to see that did you fly to to
Santa Clara together the two of you yeah
we did we did what is that what is what
does that mean very like we were like
best friends they said my big brother
you know he took me under his wings
whenever I got there and Sherman arose
how to be a professional and and I had
to go about my business so it's good
well he's the one if I'm not mistaken
said Tom Savage should be a starter you
know uh you know the time being I mean
I'm just recalling the works but you
guys were cool no we were cool
I knew how things went it I remember I
was there okay on that Thursday night
the NFL Network they kick off of
Thursday night you had just gotten your
feet wet because you got the second half
start to in that first week after you
know it was savages gig and then you got
a short wait you got a short week and if
I'm not mistaken you had no tight ends
they were in concussion protocol I you
had like left tackles playing tighter
what in the world was that like for you
that start it was different and
everything was happening quick we didn't
really practice it wall throughs for
Thursday night traveling on Wednesday
olam and playing tight in DeAndre is
really the receiver because Bruce
Ellington went down will fuller wasn't
back yet so it was really just me
hopping Lamar is trying to make
something happen and we did well I mean
you just had to run it in from midfield
that to when I was standing next to
Michael Irvin Urban's like that's why
that guy is worthy of a first round
selection or being traded up for did you
think when the Chiefs traded up for
mahomes that they were coming for you
know me my age I was sitting there and
they traded up and we saw it's not I
actually thought Buffalo was gonna take
me because we they just got the phone
with them but I
no disrespect I just didn't want to look
North them not a cold guy it's okay so I
was like okay cool then Chiefs traded up
and you know we had a good meeting enery
you know me and him are very real close
and cool but I had a feeling my gut
feeling was telling me that they were
taking someone else and so I knew for
some reason I just knew that it wasn't
me right and then you know you were
hearing with Dabo we're saying on your
behalf yeah for sure that if people did
not give you a first-round grade they
should be fired Michael Jordan and
cleats right which one was your favorite
one of pounding the table on your behalf
[Music]
I mean again the the the expectation
level for you and the fact that you have
matched it and already surpassed it but
it really you know I know for you we've
had conversations about this when you
called it in my show previously that it
really is more than just about football
for you how is your mom how is she
feeling she's feeling great she's
awesome
living her best life enjoying the ride
and joined the the games and just you
know experiencing everything she's
cancer-free she is cancer-free so that
is a blessing that's awesome and and
yeah and is it true as well
you have remodeled a Habitat for
Humanity house for hers and home you
know we had was a Habitat for Humanity
home and it was like 12 years old so you
know partnered with house and was able
to remodel the whole living room the
whole kitchen hallways everything and
and it was a pretty cool to have that
and then I recall as well that you gave
if was it your first professional
paycheck this is my first set that you
gave to some folks who works in half
material because of what was happening
with hurricane Harvey what why did you
do that at the time it was just
something that we were kind of it was
just getting back to Houston hurricane
kind of went away but everything was
starting to messed up and it was three
ladies that never complained I always
had smile on their face but I found out
through one of the workers that work
upstairs in the front office that there
were you know dealing with hard times
and no one knew about it and they never
asked anyone for anything so I just just
oh no my heart was just telling me to
you know split the check and give it to
them to have them up
it really is amazing man it really is
now is it when you said the Michael
Jordan cleats did you say that cuz he's
also a Gatorade God doesn't like that
yeah I know you know you're good in many
many different ways so you've got right
here it's the Gatorade peach blitz
it is available only during the Super
Bowl week here in Atlanta right correct
okay and and and you're with Gatorade
this year would have yes so we just you
know I'm working with Gatorades to peach
blitz
which is a really limited edition and
it's doing it for the home state Georgia
at the Peach State so you know
definitely you know getting that out
there and you know passing it out are we
so okay really really good that's good
okay and who do you think wins this
Super Bowl stuff um it's hard to go
against Brady well you have you you
almost I'm on there well your first your
first crack at it you came really right
really close
yeah I've been saying the Rams all week
and this end the Rams a week but for
some reason that I mean the Patriots are
and these type of games for sometimes
you know what's pulled through okay so
you're taking the Patriots is that
because you're not gonna play the Rams
anytime sort of yeah I'm looking out for
you right there
and so being here in Georgia being a guy
who succeeded in South Carolina are you
welcomed here in a way for sure this is
home okay yeah okay this is where you're
from Gainesville Georgia which is 30
minutes north of Atlanta okay and so
have people reached out for tickets for
this game even though you're not in it
or Odin uh so what do you think what do
you think Early's going through Oh check
it request so sure I mean the whole
state of Georgia North Carolina South
Carolina fire Tennessee although itself
is probably asking for tickets that's
really amazing
hey listen to Sean I appreciate you
stopping by here on your Super Bowl
weaknesses in in our commercial break
for our television only segment if you
see over to your left over there there's
a Rich Eisen show logo with a circle
right in the middle yeah we're gonna
give you ten footballs and we'll see if
you how many you can make through it if
you're fine with that
the Kurt Warner Pro Football Hall of
Famer he made 3 of 10 yesterday that's
it well do we have are they all foot and
they're all though she's gonna be so
upset
we had him thrown on NFL Duke footballs
and he was very upset they're really
sticky but we've got 10 Dukes for you
cool ok we'll see if you can beat him we
got breeze coming tomorrow I mean so
this is gonna be a competition ok so you
set the Shaun Watson to set the tone
here in our number two don't go anywhere
when we come back not only that the
television only segments a qualm Barkley
right behind the Shaun Watson all right
- Shaun Watson there's five footballs
here Brockman is gonna run five more
back let's see how many you can make
through the hole right there
ok that's one good look at this alright
see it comes - that's number two this is
to tie Kurt Warner oh ok let's bring
them all back hold on a minute here here
we go
it's another one right there TJ ok here
we go this is the tie Kurt Warner now to
take the lead take the lead oh I thought
that was it three more to go
take the lead Oh
- take the lead yeah there it is now to
put a little cushion here let's get a
little cushion okay a little cushion
there it is oh but four is enough excuse
me sir I'll need that football back it's
a patriot fan so how is that how does
that feel to you how's that feel - good
okay on behalf of Gatorade check out the
peach bliss if you're here in town this
week the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience